Hey, my name is Milan
and I'm gonna show you how I prepare for the European elections.
If you also care about climate change and the environment,
I want to introduce you to the European Parliament Scoreboard.
This tool scores the different European political parties
based on their voting behaviour on climate and environmental issues
in the European Parliament for the past 5 years.
So you can find a scoreboard just by Googling EU Parliament scoreboard
and you can find it on the website of CAN Europe,
who created it. So this is where you find it.
You click on it and basically
the tool is a ranking of the different European political groups,
which you will see here, and then also their scores
based on their voting behaviour on climate and environmental issues.
Now, alternatively,
you can go to national parties
and then you can just pick a country where you're from,
for example, Germany.
And then
you can see all the different parties that are running in Germany
for the EU elections and how they voted in the past 5 years.
So try it out and get informed for the elections.
And of course, go vote. I'll see you next time.